Yard House is for people who who've just
been denied alone
that's where you go after you've just
been denied alone and you're like well I
can still eat good here
it's when your bank calls you and goes
there's nothing really we can do
at this point taking a new account like
you can hear the bank saying it as they
wait on the line like you can like you
could hear like the bank being like
taking into account the income and the
credit they're like two two please yeah
yeah what what so taking into account
the income and the credit we're not able
to proceed with the car loan of six
thousand dollars they go all right all
right I understand [__] all right well
I'm gonna have to onion ring Tower and
the tuna tartar uh the Tuna the Tuna
spicy tuna whatever you put that on what
do you put it on a pizza just bring it
to the table give me a big uh cold beer
and a fat Hispanic woman